über diese schreckliche situation in den
verschiedensten pflege und seniorenheim
in deutschland möchte ich nun sprechen
mit eugen brysch er ist der chef der
deutschen hospiz bewegung hebräisch
müssen wir jetzt angst haben dass unsere
großeltern und eltern dem virus in den
heimen einfach so ausgeliefert sind also
als vorstand der deutschen stiftung
patientenschutz wenn sie so wollen geht
es ja um die frage wie versorgen wir
menschen die im pflegeheim sind
vergessen wir nicht
es sind 800.000 pflegebedürftige die in
über 12.000 heim in deutschland versorgt
werden
das heißt auch konkret das sind auch
pflegekräfte altenpflegekräfte die wir
schützen müssen und wir stellen fest
dass sowohl würzburg auch jetzt in
wolfsburg in halle
all diese fälle uns bekannt werden aber
dass die schutzkonzepte für die heime
noch nicht so entwickelt sind dass wir
sagen können es ist eine
zufriedenstellende situation und hier
gilt es dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister nicht nur die
wichtige frage der versorgung in den
krankenhäusern in den griff bekommt
sondern dann ganz besonders wichtig die
hilfe die unterstützung für die
pflegebedürftigen und für die
altenpflege kräfte vor ort in unseren
heimen in deutschland das haben sie
gerade gesagt die situation ist nicht
zufriedenstellend gibt es dann überhaupt
eine chance gegen diesen flächenbrand es
jetzt in vielen heim in deutschland
stattfindet wir brauchen tatsächlich
eine konkrete einlasskontrolle das heißt
niemand darf in ein pflegeheim kommen
auch als bewohner dieses pflegeheims der
nicht vorher getestet worden ist in
diesem heim dann muss er einige tage
isoliert werden und dann wieder getestet
werden das ist der erste schritt der
zweite strick
alle heimbewohner die einen grippalen
infekt haben müssen getestet werden wenn
sich ein positiver entwicklung heraus
tut gilt es alle heimbewohner und auch
die pflegekräfte zu testen das er hat ja
anfang der nächsten woche anfang der
letzten woche genau diese richtlinien
verändert aber dafür brauchen wir
bedingungen vor ort durch die
entsprechenden gesundheitsämter in die
dinge auch in die hand zu nehmen
zurzeit ist es immer noch so dass 70 80
oder 90 verschiedene hausärzte
unterschiedliche patienten in einem
pflegeheim haben es muss doch klar sein
dass das chaos vorprogrammiert ist wenn
das geschieht deswegen brauchen wir
jetzt dringend eine taskforce auf
kommunaler ebene rauch gebildet aus
mobilen ärzten aus krankenhäusern und
niedergelassenen ärzten die die
versorgung komplett übernehmen die
medizinische in einem solchen pflegeheim
das ist überfällig und gilt jetzt auch
in richtlinien festzuschreiben
denn wir wollen die schwächsten in
unserer gesellschaft ja schützen
sonst macht es ja gar keinen sinn dass
wir alle zu hause bleiben dass wir alle
abstand halten wenn es uns nicht gelingt
die schwächsten dort zu stützen wo sie
leben und das ist in der regel ja eng
zusammen gefasst
in der pflege in deutschland in einem
heim wenn wir jetzt einmal auf die
heimbewohner blicken für sie ist die
situation natürlich ganz besonders
schrecklich aus sicherheitsgründen kommt
es momentan zur totalen abschottung was
auch oft einsamkeit für alte menschen
bedeutet und dazu noch die angst dass
sie sich jetzt mit dem virus infizieren
könnten als die größte risikogruppe
haben sie mit menschen gesprochen die in
diesen heimen leben wie sie jetzt mit
dieser situation umgehen
ja in der regel können wir immer nur mit
angehörigen sprechen weil vergessen wir
das nicht es ist ja in wolfsburg eine
sondersituation dass wir dort zu viele
demenziell erkrankte menschen haben in
deutschen heimen sind 70 prozent der
pflegebedürftigen demenziell erkrankt
das heißt sie erleben nun ein trauma das
auf einmal menschen die sie jeden tag
gesehen haben doch so hoffe ich immer
mehr auch mit einem gesichtsschutz
ein nasen- und mundschutz ausgestattet
mit desinfektionsmitteln eben auf einmal
diese menschen näher kommen stellen sie
sich einen verwirrten menschen vor was
das für ihn bedeutet und wir erfahren
natürlich auch von sehr vielen
angehörigen die sagen ich würde gerne
per skype oder in eine andere beziehung
aufbauen wenigstens ein hallo sagen
meiner mutter und mein vater und ich
sehe aber auch dass viele
altenpflegekräfte dann ihr mobile phone
nehmen und genau solche verbindungen
herstellen wir brauchen diese verbindung
weil es gilt ja auch mut zu machen auch
die dinge jetzt anzupacken und es gilt
erst recht die bedingungen wenn sie so
wollen die schutzpläne so auszurichten
dass wir wirklich allen helfen die vor
ort hilfe notwendig haben und das sind
bitte nicht nur die menschen im
altenpflegeheim das sind unsere alten
pflegekräfte das sind aber auch die
vielen kranken die fliehen
pflegebedürftige chronisch kranken
ihr vorstandsvorsitzender vor wenigen
tagen selber geschrieben er selber herr
döpfner ist ja auch chronisch kranke
indem er uns gesagt hat ich leide an
asthma und bin damit betroffen vergessen
wenn ich es sind sechs millionen
menschen also nicht nur die alten
sondern auch die chronisch kranken dem
herzkranken die asthmakranken den blick
nehmen müssen und dafür gilt der schutz
konzepte zu entwickeln also bevor wir
rausgehen bevor wir wieder in normalität
zurückkommen muss jetzt endlich mit
aller kraft dort geholfen werden wo es
notwendig ist diese anstrengung muss
erfüllt werden bevor wir wieder in ein
normales leben zurück kommen sonst
beantworten wir viele menschen die krank
werden wir verantworten viele tote und
das darf nicht sein weil es gilt ja
möglich zu retten und gut in sicherheit
zu bringen von diesem virus in cambridge
für diese einschätzung